another thing that we have been tracking
and chris this was unplanned but we're
going to tack it on to the end of this
well we've been going for an hour and 15
minutes we may as well keep going the
nfl and i want to get this right this
comes from mike garafolo of the nfl the
nfl will proceed with the draft on april
23 to 25 but will cancel public events
in las vegas the league is exploring
innovative ways for how the process will
be conducted ultimately look here's the
thing
april 23 there aren't gonna be any
sports between now and then unless
knucklehead dana white keeps conducting
ufc events which somebody needs to tell
him to stop it stop it now
even if ufc continues major sports will
not april 23 will be the return of sport
it'll be the draft and it will be bigger
than ever all they need is roger goodell
sitting in a chair slippers and a pipe
and a newspaper and his dog and a
crackling fire reading off the names one
after another and it'll be the most
watched draft of all time
agreed you're right
i'm starving already and it's only been
a few days without sports okay so yes
i mean if that happened you're right we
don't need much just have them say the
pics show us some highlights of these
players and we'll all be tuned in and
yeah i'd like if it does come to that
i'd like to see them do something
creative with roger goodell like you
know maybe he's sitting in the middle of
that bellagio fountain just all by
himself with like an nfl logo behind him
you know i talked about last week i'd
love to see him like on top of the
empire state building or like on the top
of like the freedom tower here in new
york city uh and he just got an
unbelievable view of the nfl shield
behind them and just do it like that
whatever it is but um i know by that
time if we have no sports by then we
will be starving as a country for some
action and
it's not going to take much to get us
all to tune in
and i think we'll all realize that
the the people who show up are just
props it's background it's aimed at
making us all think it's a bigger deal
than it really is right and and yeah
maybe that draws in a few thousand extra
people who think wow if all those people
are watching it and and they're there
maybe i should care about this too
but
this is going to be i'm not going to
suggest
it's it's not going to be super bowl
level ratings but we need to project
forward six weeks from now
the the i mean we're already going star
crazy without sports you draw it out to
april 23 and that's the event and it
will be built up and that's our
diversion that's our oasis that's our
distraction from all this other crap
i i think it could be no i think it will
be the biggest draft ever from a rating
standpoint the question is how big will
the ratings be
yeah no i i would agree i think if this
was to be the case going forward it
would be huge ratings and and we have
storylines that are special with this
draft too with the whole quarterback
situation chase young these superstar
wide receivers i mean there's a few
story lines i think within this draft
where you just go whoa this could be
crazy this could be a cool year we could
have some real action you know in the
top 10 people jockeying for position for
the quarterback they want for the
receiver they want for chase young
whatever it may be uh it has the the you
know the potential to really be a really
cool draft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports